Как добиться успеха в любом деле,
начиная с нуля? Я много размышлял над
этим принципом и над этим правилом и в
жизни очень часто его применял. Я
размышлял над тем, как, ну, и что нужно
делать для того, чтобы с нуля очень
быстро добиться успеха в любом деле. И
применял в различных ситуациях в жизни и
спрашивал других людей. И я каждый раз
убеждаюсь, насколько сильно это правило
и насколько 100% железно она работает. К
сожалению, большинство людей это не
принимает, не применяют и не знают об
этом правиле. Проблема всех людей в том,
что когда они начинают какое-то дело,
они начинают с того, чтобы хотят
получать много и сразу, отдавать
постепенно и помаленьку. Приведу вам
такой пример. Когда человек приходит на
работу, он сразу выставляет все свои
хотелки. Хочу за такую-то зарплату, хочу
вот это, хочу это, хочу это, хочу это.
Что дальше происходит? Это вызывает
определённое отторжение со стороны
работодателя. Потому что когда человек
вываливает всё, что он хочет,
получается,
работодатель становится в позицию, в
ситуацию, когда он вынужден покупать
кота в мешке за непомерно большую цену.
И, соответственно,
на ваше обращение, на ваше резюме будет
меньше отклика. Или, например, когда вы
начинаете какой-то бизнес, вы сразу
выставляете вот такую цену или какие-то
особые требования. В результате у вас
мало покупателей. Для того, чтобы
добиться успеха в любом деле с нуля, вы
должны действовать конт интуитивно, на
180° наоборот. Вы должны отдавать много
и сразу, а получать помаленьку и
постепенно. Для того, чтобы понять,
почему это правило настолько важно и как
оно работает, ставьте лайк, и мы
продолжим дальше. Когда вы начинаете
любое дело с нуля, не имеет значения это
бизнес, общественная деятельность,
политическая деятельность, не имеет
абсолютно никакого значение. Запомните
это правило, ещё раз подчеркну, оно
очень контринтуитивно.
Отдавать много и сразу, а получать
постепенно и помаленьку. Это приводит
железнобетонно, железобетонно со
стопроцентной вероятностью к успеху. Как
это работает в жизни и вообще откуда я
взял это правило? Я в своей жизни
сталкивался много раз с такими
ситуациями. И, а, так как я всю жизнь
много работаю с волонтёрами, я заметил
такую вещь. Это на эту мысль меня
натолкнул один случай с волонтёром.
Когда он пришёл выполнять определённую
работу, так как он волонтёр на
бесплатной основе, то он начал
предлагать делать не то, что не только
основную работу, но ещё много
дополнительной работы. Он готов и то
сделать, и это сделать, и это сделать.
Оказывается, он ещё разбирается в IT,
оказывается, он разбирается в
программировании, оказывается, он умеет
настраивать Excel, оказывается, он ещё
может
вести вечеринку, быть там одной и так
далее. И таким образом я заметил такую
вещь, что я подспудно захотел больше с
ним работать. Я начал больше с ним
работать. Через какое-то время он
продолжал также отдавать всё много и
сразу. В какой-то момент я почувствовал
внутри, что этот человек
мне лучше платить деньги этому человеку,
иначе он уйдёт, либо его запал пропадёт
и так далее. Я начал платить ему деньги.
Дальше в какой-то момент, а это были
небольшие деньги. Я понял, что если мне
не поднять цену до рыночной цены, то он
может уйти. А у меня мысль была такая:
"Блин, классный парень. А надо платить
ему рыночную цену, иначе он уйдёт". Я
поднял до рыночной цены. И так как
человек, парень этот продолжал работать
дальше и выкладываться по полной
программе и отдавать всё и сразу, то в
какой-то момент я начал его поднимать а
по карьерной лестнице, а,
соответственно, увеличивая а его
заработную плату. Таким образом, он
достиг очень высоких позиций за
достаточно короткое время. Буквально в
течение полгода он вырос до очень
хороших позиций. у меня в компании. И я
для себя понял, вот когда я посмотрел со
стороны, что же произошло, я понял, что
он делал. Он это делал неосознанно,
конечно, а из-за того, что он по натуре
такой человек, но он, оказывается,
действительно отдавал много и сразу, а
брал постепенно и помаленьку. Я
представил, вот если бы он пришёл ко мне
и занимался бы только тем делом, ради
которого он пришёл, то есть волонтёр
пришёл там, а, на какое-то одно дело и
занимался бы только этим, то он бы не
раскрыл бы свой талант, свои способности
мне, соответственно, я был не был бы
заинтересован в нём дальше. А так как он
отдавал много и сразу, то я увидел
несоответствие того, что он просит у
меня и то, что даёт. И это заставило
меня переживать и бояться, что этот
человек уйдёт, потому что слишком
большая ценность против э той цены,
которую он запрашивает. И таким образом,
а, он очень быстро поднялся у меня, э,
по карьерной лестнице в компании, когда,
а, я победил во всех уголовных делах, в
международных судах, которые у меня на
меня возбудило наше правительство. Я
вернулся в Казахстан и практически сидел
у разбитого корыта. Правительство, ну,
конкретно Назарбаев забрал у меня все
мои активы, и мне надо было начинать с
нуля. всю мою репутацию они разрушили,
там, поливая мо меня помоями, а, и
обзывая там мошенникам, преступникам и
так далее. Репутация была моя на нуле, и
я думал, чем бы заняться. И я понял, что
первое, что я должен для сделать для
себя, во-первых, поднять свою самооценку
и, э, двигаться дальше. А как поднять
свою самооценку, я понял, для этого мне
нужно создать спрос на себя, то есть
почувствовать свою востребованность для
других людей. Потому что, когда вас
преследуют, прессуют и обзывают
негодяем, мошенникам, э-э, там,
преступникам и так далее, то в какой-то
момент ваша самооценка падает, вы
чувствуете свою ненужность, и вы
думаете: "Блин, всё, всё, м, всему конец
подняться невозможно". И я для себя
выставил тогда такую цепочку, что мне
надо поднять свою самооценку. Для того,
чтобы поднять свою самооценку, мне
нужно, а, создать востребованность на
свою востребованность, то есть, чтоб на
меня был спрос. И тогда я подумал:
"Хорошо, что есть у меня? У меня есть
опыт, у меня есть знания. Кому они
нужны?" Они нужны молодым людям. У
молодых людей энергии много, а опыта
знаний нету. У меня энергии поменьше,
зато очень много
знания и опыта. И я начал бесплатно
читать много лекций в университетах.
Более того, я ходил в парке, э-э, в
парке президента, а за мной ходили
молодые люди, задавали вопросы. Это
дошло до того, что за мной ходило 1.100
человек. Группа у нас называется Бизнес
Lifehaхакеer Group. 1.100 человек
подключали мне микрофон в зуме, со мной
ходили в парке, в других городах и так
далее. Я зада это отвечал на их вопросы,
они задавали мне вопросы. Я отвечал,
отвечал, отвечал. Всё это дело
бесплатно. Я начал организовывать кучу
экспедиций в рамках на Mat Explorer.
Компанию создал на Mat Explorer. Всё это
бесплатно. И постепенно вокруг меня
образовалось огромное количество,
большое количество людей, моих фанатов,
последователей и так далее, и так далее.
Это позволило мне дальше создать уже
образовательную платформу, дальше уже,
э, заниматься социальными сетями. Ко мне
начали тянуться люди, ко мне начали
тянуться специалисты, эксперты и так
далее, и так далее. И постепенно я опять
встал на ноги таким образом. Ещё один
пример приведу. Буквально года два
назад, а ко мне приезжал Игорь Баков,
ну, российский миллиардер, а, мой
хороший товарищ. Он приезжал в гости у
меня дома, они остановились, жили. И
Игорь мне задал вопрос, говорит: "А вот
я снимался в передаче,
по-моему, секретный миллионер, что ли,
называется". И вот там такая же история
говорит: "Вот если бы ты попал, ты бы
как с нуля поднялся?" И я ему
рассказываю эту историю. Я бы, говорю,
шёл, увидел бы деревню, зашёл в деревню,
а, вижу кривой забор. Я бы начал править
забор кривой, там что-то помогать,
что-то делать, либо убирать, либо
починить дверь, либо лампочку крутить.
Ну, что-то делал бы бесплатно. Или вижу,
что кто-то работает, например, в
огороде, мог бы подойти и сказать: "Вы
картошко паете, давайте я вам помогу".
От помощи навряд ли кто-либо откажется.
Но что произойдёт? Если ты начнёшь
добросовестно это делать, помогать там
копать картошку, то хозяин почувствует к
тебе сразу симпатию, и он обязательно
предложит тебе там кружку молока, зайти
попить чай после там, как после того,
как поработали обязательно. А раз
пригласил на чай, то там разговоры. А
раз разговоры, то есть возможность
полностью раскрыть, сказать: "А что вы
это, например, у вас свет так или почему
у вас интернета нет?" Давайте я вам
сделаю, давайте я вам вот это сделаю, а
давайте вам это сделаю. И это вам даёт
возможность, так как внимание теперь вы
захватили внимание, он готов вас
слушать. Потому что если вы с улицы
сразу придёте, а, и что-то у него будете
просить, то он вас слушать не будет. А
когда вы для него сделали, вы захватили
внимание, и он готов вас слушать. И в
этот момент ваша задача максимально
предложить ему все возможности, которые
есть у вас. Какими-то возможностями он
обязательно воспользуется. И этим самым
он почувствует себя ещё более должным. А
он почувствует, что он должен что-то для
вас сделать. Как минимум вы 100%
обеспечите себе на шлек и еду с ходу в
первый же день. Более того, когда вы
продолжите также помогать делать для
него всё, отремонтировать мотоцикл, ещё
что-то сделать, а вас сразу же пойдёт
слух по всей деревне, потому что
деревня, а, там всё быстро, сарафанка
работает очень быстро, сразу же, а,
пойдёт слух в деревне, обязательно
кому-то ещё надо будет отремонтировать
мотоцикл, обязательно кому-то ещё что
надо, ещё что-то надо, и вы будете
делать, и люди вас будут кормить, давать
приют и так далее, и в какой-то момент
они просто начнут вам платить деньги.
или предлагать деньги, и вы уже начнёте
постепенно делать это за деньги. Потом
больше, больше, больше вы можете
организовать
для них там продажу, условно того же
картофеля в город, ещё что-то, ещё
что-то. И в конечном итоге этот мир
устроен таким образом, что ваша цена
всегда вас найдёт. Проблема в том, что
люди ставят на себя цену и сразу хотят
её получить от этого мира. Но это когда
вы в знакомой среде, это понятно. А
когда вы попали в незнакомый мир, нужно
сначала показать миру свою ценность
полностью, а потом мир за счёт рыночных
механизмов выставить на вас цену. Если
вы встречали такую же ситуацию либо сами
так делали, напишите, пожалуйста, в
комментариях. Мне будет интересно
почитать. И я уверен, будет интересно
почитать всем другим зрителям этого
канала, как это в жизни работает. Но я
вам точно говорю, 100% это работает в
жизни. в любой стране мира. Кстати,
когда вы попадаете в незнакомую страну,
если вы будете применять этот алгоритм,
просто с вероятностью дня и ночи вы
будете достигать успеха. Это этот
механизм работает всегда. Поэтому
сначала покажите этому миру свою
ценность, и после этого этот мир
заплатит вам цену. Это только один из
секретов, которые вам помогут
гарантированно достигать успеха с нуля в
любой незнакомой среде и любой ситуации.
Этот и другие лайфхаки, которые могут
перевернуть всю вашу жизнь, я разбираю в
своём Telegram-канале. Подписывайтесь,
ссылка внизу. А,
Маруглааньч, многие вспомнят примеры из
жизни, да и в любых вот
предпринимательских кругах я слышу
разговоры, как один предприниматель
хвастается, говорит: "Да у меня там
сотрудница за 500 долларов в месяц кучу
всего ведёт. по управленке там и вообще
замечательно или там, да, у меня вот
этот оператор уже второй год работает,
всего там за 300 долларов в месяц и
замеча и радуется. То есть чаще слышатся
наоборот другие речи, когда
предприниматели с радостью делятся тем,
что какой-то сотрудник стабильный за
небольшие деньги, делает довольно много
работы и не просит повышения и как бы
радуется. То есть такое ощущение, что
этот принцип взаимности, да, взаимных
вложений сразмерной оплаты труда, он
применим только с особо осознанными
людьми, а в реальной жизни это редко
встречается. Вот как в таких случаях
быть?
На самом деле этот принцип работает
везде и всегда, не только с осознанными
людьми. Например, если а вот ситуация,
когда там предприниматель рад платить
небольшие деньги человеку, который
выполняет огромное количество работы и
кажется, блин, он всю жизнь так и
проведёт, получая там 500 долларов, а и
этот предприниматель не заинтересован
поднимать ему цену. Да, так оно и есть.
Но не надо надеяться на то, что ваш
работодатель поднимет вам цену сам. Вы
должны распространять информацию о своих
способностях как можно большему кругу
людей. Поэтому я говорю, мир должен
узнать о ваших способностях, и тогда мир
даст вам вашу цену. Не конкретный
человек, если вы придёте в ту же самую
деревню, почините забор, в тихаря
отремонтируйте мотоцикл, в тихаря будете
пахать, то всем людям выгоден такой
человек. и хозяин вам не не будет
поднимать цену. Но если это вы будете
делать и люди будут это видеть, ээ вы
будете рассказывать, вы будете помогать
не только ему, а ещё и другим, тогда все
будут видеть и знать про вашу ценность.
И этот хозяин, который сейчас платит, а
он будет бояться потерять вас, и тогда
он начнёт повышать вам цену. Поэтому,
когда вы занимаетесь любой работой в
любой компании, всегда делайте свою
основную работу. Плюс на волонтёрских
условиях ещё оказываете услуги на
стороне. Вот тогда мир о вас больше
узнает, вам будет больше предлагать э
различных возможностей, и вы преуспеете.
M.